bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo
aujourd'hui on parle méthodologique dans
la démarche des sciences sociales
les élèves ne comprennent pas toujours
ce qu'est et comment construire un
modèle d'analysé
cette vidéo a pour objectif de les aider
à comprendre cette étape importante de
la démarche des sciences sociales ont
fait une vidéo je vous présenterai un
modèle d' analyse très connu
l'explication du site par emile durkheim
vous aurez également droit à un petit
cadeau made in sociaux tech le modèle
d'analysé est une représentation
théorique abstraite et simplifiée de la
réalité il s'agit de la réponse
théorique que l'on donne à la question
de recherche
il est basé sur des concepts mis en
relation dans des hypothèses les
concepts sont des constructions
abstraites qui permettent de cibler de
manière précise et rigoureuse les
phénomènes que l'on souhaite comprendre
ou expliquer les hypothèses sont quant à
elles des propositions de réponses que
l'on doit vérifier ou réfuter autrement
dit ce sont des réponses provisoire
elles sont généralement de deux formes
dans le cas de la première forme et il
s'agit d'une mise en relation entre un
phénomène est un concept par exemple les
marches pour le climat sont un mouvement
social
nous avons bien un concept qui est
appliquée à un fait social dans leur
seconde forme les hypothèses sont aussi
une relation entre des concepts ou une
variable dépendante est expliquée par
une ou plusieurs autres variables dites
indépendantes par exemple une cohésion
sociale faible conduit à une
augmentation des suicides dans la
construction de votre modèle d' analyse
vous devrez d'abord identifier et
développer les concepts utile à la
formulation de vos hypothèses
cela aura normalement été fait lors des
étapes d'exploration et de définition de
la problématique
il faudra ensuite convertir ces concepts
et toutes leurs composantes en
indicateurs observable en effet il est
difficile d'observer directement dans la
réalité la cohésion sociale par contre
on peut plus facilement mesurer le
nombre de personnes qu'un individu
côtoie chaque semaine qu'il s'agit là
d'un indicateur ce travail de traduction
qui est en fait un travail
d'opérationnalisation est indispensable
si vous voulez être en mesure de
vérifier vos hypothèses
ensuite vous formuler vos hypothèses
soit en les construisant vous
mais c'est parfois plus compliqué soit
en les empruntant à un auteur et en les
transposant à votre objet d'étude pour
être valable aux hypothèses doivent
répondre à deux critères
elles doivent être vérifiable est
falsifiable c'est à dire que vous devez
avoir les moyens de les vérifier ou de
les réfuter il doit être possible de les
reconnaître comme fausse c'est un moment
charnière de votre recherche
car dès que le modèle d'anaïs sera posée
vous aurez fini le travail théorique et
vous passerez au travail empirique
c'est à dire au travail d'observation de
la réalité du travail de terrain à ce
moment vos hypothèses devienne votre fil
rouge en lieu et place de votre question
de recherche la suite de votre recherche
consistera exclusivement en la
vérification de cette hypothèse est donc
vous devrez collecter l'information par
rapport à cet objectif le modèle d'
analyse formulée par durkheim et qui
expliquent le suicide repose sur une
hypothèse principale le taux de suicide
dépend du niveau de cohésion sociale
d'une société il s'agit d'une hypothèse
de la deuxième forme nous l'avons déjà
vu ou deux concepts sont mis en relation
la variable dépendante le taux de
suicide indépendante le niveau de la
cohésion sociale
si le taux de suicide n'a pas besoin
d'être développé ni d'être traduit en un
indicateur puisqu'il s'agit déjà d'un
indicateur durkheim définira d'abord ce
qu'est le suicide pour que ce concept
soit bien clair pour tous ensuite il
développera en profondeur ce concept de
cohésion sociale et distinguera une
cohésion sociale forte d'une cohésion
sociale faible ce qui lui permettra
d'avoir deux causes à deux types de
suicides totalement différent le suicide
égoïste en cas de cohésion sociale
faible et le suicide altruiste dans le
cas d'une cohésion sociale plus forte
enfin il complète son modèle d' analyse
par une troisième forme de suicide
le suicide anomique qui correspond au
suicide qui se produit quand on est dans
une situation d'anomie c'est à dire une
situations d'affaiblissement des normes
sociales
nous reviendrons prochainement dans une
vidéo sur ce concept intéressant
d'anomie le modèle d' analyse de
durkheim comporte bien différents
concepts taux de suicide suicide anomie
cohésion sociale ils sont mis en
relation au sein de différentes
hypothèses articulé aussi entre elles
par des liens logiques c'est un bel
exemple de modèles d'annales
en complément à cette vidéo je vous
offre les notes de cours que vous
trouverez dans le descriptif et sur le
blog de la société
ces notes de cours reprennent de
nombreux exemples et sont bien plus
développée que cette vidéo si cette
vidéo restera figé pour l'éternité sur
les serveurs de youtube ce n'est pas le
cas des commentaires et des notes de
cours qui peuvent être toujours modifier
n'hésitons pas à commenter cette vidéo a
rectifié éventuellement les petites
approximations que l'on pourrait faire
dans une vidéo de ce type 1 qui est une
vidéo de vulgarisation et je vous dis à
très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo de
sciences sociales on travaille est pas
un amusement dans les sciences sociales
[Musique]